depuis deux ans et plantation de saules
sont au travail dans l'est de montréal
on veut voir si ces arbres sont capable
de décontaminer le sol relève tout
technologies s'est diffusé les plantes
pour régler une problématique
environnementale
ailleurs on s'attaque ou traitement des
eaux à saint roch de l'achigan
l'ancienne station d'épuration côtoient
celles de l'avenir
ce marais filtrant plantes et de soul
traite une partie des eaux usées de
l'usiné depuis deux ans d efficacité
d'enlèvement donc l'eau qui sort des
filtres répond tout à fait aux normes du
ministère
donc c'est concluant on essaie aussi de
traiter les eaux récupérées d'un site
d'enfouissement
mais que c'est de faire une application
qui est contrôlé d'eau contaminée sur le
sol ou des sols sont plantés après ça
c'est vraiment de contrôler la dose
d'irrigation pour pour quoi que ce soit
trop pour les plantes donc juste donné
assez pour les plantes et pour le seul
et ça fonctionne on a perdu la couleur
noire noire autres puis en termes
d'odeurs également l'eau les sols sont
de véritables pompe qui aspire l'eau
mais aussi des contaminants ces
contaminants une fois transformé
deviennent des fertilisants qui double
et triple la croissance des saules
l'effet de la zone toxiques
les feuilles sont beaucoup plus vercol
s'il se voit
en bonne santé le québec a du retard sur
certains pays d'europe qui utilisent
déjà ces technologies au cours des cinq
prochaines années
le jardin botanique de montréal veut
faire connaître les phytotechnologies au
grand public dans notre parcours on va
retrouver des toits verts voire trop
retrouver des bassins de rétention pour
les stationnements pour récupérer les
eaux de pluie qu'on peut très bien
réutiliser pour arroser les
plates-bandes de plantes ornementales
dans le jardin des plantes aquatiques
on pourra filtrer l'eau souillée et
recycler les éléments utiles au plan les
marais filtrant fondamentalement ce
n'est que ça c'est un travail d'équipé
entre les plantes les micro-organismes
et le gravier on croit que le public est
prêt à faire sa part
c'est comme ceux qui d'un coup la
présence des plantes dans notre
environnement prend une signification
beaucoup plus contraire térieur en plus
de traiter les eaux usées de petites
municipalités du sol pourront être
récoltés puis transformé en mur
antibruit ou même en paillis rien n'est
perdu dans cette économie circulaire ici
à nourrice despatie radio-canada saint
roch de l'achigan